on finnegan's wake
i think maybe correct me if i'm wrong
you're using kind of finnegan's wake to
give one perspective on what madness is
of what's going on in the mind how much
of that
is uh that we're simply unable
to communicate with the person on the
other side of of their mind like there's
almost like a
a little person inside the brain and
they have some circuitry that's used to
communicate emotion communicate ideas to
the outside world and there's something
about that circuitry that makes it
difficult to communicate with a little
person on the other side so if you look
at what shows up in schizophrenia with
many cases the
what we call thought disorders what we
call
uh the
the individual speech symptoms of
schizophrenia
finnegan's wake is is loaded with them
and it's it's just full of them we we
talk about uh
clang associations in schizophrenia
where the word that is said is
echoes in some way the previous word and
it's we call that a clang association
because there's no other reason than the
similarity of the sound like a like a
clang of a
of a garage door being hit
and it has a
uh and sometimes it's not even a word
and we call that a neologism a new word
being created and of course finnegan's
awake is full of that and then
uh we we also in schizophrenia where
there's what we call loose associations
or tangential thought processes of
course full of that where things just go
off in directions that are
not linear or logical
and
you can't read
finnegan's wake i think without
um certainly a psychiatrist you can't
read it without thinking about
schizophrenia
and then when we look at
the families of people with
schizophrenia and joyce was no exception
there very often are people within the
family who are on the spectrum some have
it
some are
able to see it from a distance from a
safe distance
there's an association between
schizophrenia and what we call
schizotypal personality disorder where
people are not quite in this
severe state of schizophrenia but have
some magical thinking have some unusual
thought patterns very often those are
family members of people with
schizophrenia so this points to this
again to this idea that that there is a
range even along
this very severe
very genetic biological illness that
human beings dwell on different spots
along that spectrum i should mention
that we have my friend sergey pulling up
stuff young sergei or old sergey i don't
know what to call you but
uh there's drafts of finnegan's quake
yeah i actually saw pictures of this
from um
i think it was on instagram or something
these are early giraffes of finnegan's
wave and it's so beautiful to see for
people who are just listening there's
just random paragraphs and writing all
over the page with stuff crossed out and
it's great to see that joyce himself was
thinking in this kind of way as
um as you're putting it together how
much do you think he was thinking about
schizophrenia the schizophrenic mind i
think a lot i think you know it's it's
known that his his daughter suffered
from from schizophrenia and uh the this
is what's depicted here on the page is
something that i'm sure he either felt
himself and some some level was able to
access this non-linearity of of
processing
or had seen enough in family
uh that he he knew what it was and was
able to to reflect it down in black and
white on the paper so it was what he was
able to do is was quite authentic in
that sense
of course
i don't want to
pigeonhole him he was doing much more
than that it was much more than than
talking about altered human
thought processes and thought disorders
but that was an aspect that he was so
good at representing that it had to be
intentional to some extent
you